SHANE GLASS: Hey, there, and
welcome to Google Cloud Next
On Air.
Today we'll be talking about
how public data could help data
scientists, researchers,
public health agencies,
and others combat the novel
2019 coronavirus, also known
as COVID-19, and help
flatten the curve
of cases around the globe.
My name is Shane Glass.
I'm a developer advocate
here at Google Cloud,
covering business
intelligence, and I'm also
the tech lead for the cloud
public data sets program.
I'm thankful to be joined today
by my co-presenter Javier.
Javier, you want to take a
minute to introduce yourself?
JAVIER DE LA TORRE: Sure.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Javier de
la Torre, and then
the co-founder of CARTO.
SHANE GLASS: Awesome,
thanks, Javier.
So here's a quick outline of
what we intend to cover today.
So let's start with a quick
overview of Google Cloud's
public data sets program.
We currently offer more than
180 public machine learning
ready data sets available
in our products,
both in structured data sets in
our serverless data warehouse
BigQuery and
unstructured data sets,
like satellite imagery
in Google Cloud Storage.
And we work hard to ensure
that each of these data sets
are as up to date as possible
according to the requirements
of each individual data set.
Sometimes this means
real time updates,
like our cryptocurrency
blockchains,
and sometimes this means annual
updates, like US Census Bureau
boundaries.
We're also working with
our partners, team members,
and customers to identify new
data sets of interest that
can expand our catalog as well.
So ultimately, what
does this mean for you?
There's no need
to worry about ETL
for some of the most high value
public data sets in the world.
We preload these core
data sets, and it
makes life easier for the data
analyst and data scientist
by reducing time to
get started and helping
you unlock new insights
in your existing data.
Now as the COVID-19
pandemic truly
began to spread
across the globe,
we recognized the need
for expanded access
to analyze data that
documents the spread
of the and its impacts.
In March of 2020, we
announced our COVID-19
public data sets program,
which now contains
more than 20 data sets.
To make it as easy as possible
for researchers and data
scientists to combat
COVID-19, these data sets
are preloaded into
BigQuery and continually
updated to reduce the
time to analyze the data.
In addition to the
free access we provide
for all public
data sets, queries
against COVID-19 public data
sets are provided at no cost
through September 15 to maximize
the ability for researchers
to fight COVID-19.
These include data sets
detailing COVID-19 confirmed
cases and deaths
around the world,
like those available
from "The New York
Times," the Italian Department
of Civil Protection,
and the European Center
for Disease and Prevention
and Control, data sets that
contain information about how
governments are acting to combat
COVID-19, such as the Oxford
COVID-19 Government Response
Tracker, that describes policy
actions that have been
put into place to mitigate
the impacts of
COVID-19, and data
sets that can
contextualize outbreaks,
such as the US Census Bureau's
American Community Survey.
We think this can
truly make a difference
in flattening the curve.
Let's pause here for a
second for those unfamiliar
with BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
highly scalable enterprise data
warehouse solution.
It's fully managed
and serverless,
offers real time insights
from streaming data,
has built ML out
of the box, and has
a high speed in memory BI
Engine for faster and reporting
and analysis.
BigQuery is designed to
make data analysts and data
scientists more
productive, and it's
a secure offering that offers
data encryption by default
both in transit and
at rest to ensure
that your data are protected.
So let's get back to the
public data to combat COVID-19.
Now we believe that the
COVID-19 public data sets
we are hosting, combined with
the high powered analysis
platforms like
BigQuery and CARTO,
can help support the mitigation
of the impact of COVID-19
in three primary ways.
The first of these is informing
individual decision making.
And in my opinion, this
might be the most important.
This is critical to slowing
the spread of the virus
by helping
individuals understand
the importance of
social distancing,
the importance of wearing a
mask, and other safeguards.
It can also help researchers and
public health officials better
understand which policy actions
are having a positive impact.
Now, the second
of these use cases
is analyzing the second
order of public health
impacts of the pandemic.
Secondary public health
impacts of the virus
include potential food security
among employees and industries
that are most likely to be
displaced by the COVID-19
impact on the economy,
according to the public health
officials we've worked with.
Now these data
sets are typically
used by public health officials
to identify people and regions
that are dealing with
impacts of the pandemic other
than the virus itself.
Data sets such as Google's
Community Mobility Reports,
the Census Bureau's
American Community Survey,
and global health and population
trends from the World Bank
are crucial to help public
health officials better
understand and ensure that
the full public health impact
of the pandemic is mitigated.
And finally, we're
helping inform
individual economic decision
making, such as helping
governments make an informed
data driven decision
about reopening economies.
Combining these data
sets, such as data
about COVID-19 cases
from USA Facts,
the Oxford university Government
Policy Response Tracker,
aggregated hospital capacity
from the American Hospital
Association, and Geotab's
commercial mobility impacts,
government officials
and businesses
can make an informed decision
about the risks and benefits
of reopening their economies.
This can help states, such as
the five Western states that
make up the Western states pack,
take a data driven approach
to measuring their published
criteria for reopening
economies, including
the ability of hospitals
to handle a new wave of
patients and protect those most
vulnerable to COVID-19.
So let's take a look at some
examples of how Google Cloud
customers are already
seeing success
using COVID-19 public data
sets in the three categories
we've laid out.
The first of these is
the state of Oklahoma.
State officials in Oklahoma
collaborated with teams
from across Google Cloud
to develop and launch
a Looker dashboard that helps
keep their citizens informed
of the current status.
This helps reinforce the
importance of public health
efforts by providing
citizens transparency
into the decision making
process and the impacts
of these decisions.
The second of these is analyzing
the second order public health
impacts of the pandemic.
Descartes Labs has built
and widely published
an analysis that shows
the reduction of pollution
and other emissions
within areas that
have high number
of COVID-19 cases
and that are currently
under stay at home
or safer at home orders.
And the final example is
from the Emergent Alliance,
a data analytics
coalition that's
spearheaded by Rolls Royce.
The Emergent Alliance
is a response
from a growing number
of global brands
who believe in using the power
of big data for the greater
good.
By combining private
and public data sets,
the Emergent Alliance aims
to accelerate and smooth
economic recovery from
the COVID-19 crisis.
Their stated mission is to
help governments, businesses,
and communities help each
other in the recovery
and provide better insights
through better data that
provide better
outcomes for everybody.
Now a lot of this amazing
work is only possible
because of the powerful
analytics platforms
that are available.
Now one of these is CARTO,
a leading spatial analytics
company headquartered
in New York City.
I'm joined today all the
way from Madrid, Spain
by their founder and chief
strategy officer, Javier de la
Torre, to talk a
little more about how
they are helping their
customers leverage
public data to combat COVID-19.
Javier.
JAVIER DE LA TORRE:
Thanks, Shane.
I'm pretty excited to be here
today collaborating with Google
on COVID-19 mitigation.
We have seen an explosion on
usage of maps and location
intelligence to fight COVID-19.
It's like the entire population
had cut almost a 101 course
of maps and mobility recently.
And that's because,
I'd like to say,
there's never been a more
important time to geography.
Understanding the
geography of the pandemic
and the mobility
of the population
is one of the few tools
that we have right now
available to fight COVID.
At Carto, we have been pretty
busy over the last months,
at the beginning
of the pandemic,
working with different
governments and organizations
on the response to COVID.
And BigQuery has been
a fundamental part
to handle very large spatial
datasets on these use cases.
But before [INAUDIBLE]
we do that,
I just want to give you a
little quick intro about Carto.
So Carto is a location
intelligence platform.
We help organizations analyze
and visualize location data.
Let me tell you a little
bit about what it means.
One way that I like to explain
what location is-- location
intelligence is,
is by explaining
the difference between
understanding where
and understanding why.
You want to look
at where there's
more COVID-19 cases, you
will likely use a BI tool,
such as Looker.
But if you want
to understand why
there are more cases on one
place versus another, if you
want to understand what are the
characteristics of those places
that makes them feel
more vulnerable to COVID,
then you need to create what
we call a spatial model.
And for doing that,
you need Carto.
So with Carto,
think about creating
spatial models that
help you understand
why something happened so.
Now we provide
these capabilities
in a product with
different interfaces.
We work with data scientists,
analysts, and developers.
And more important, I think very
relevant in this case, Carto.
We like to say, comes also
with batteries included.
Most of our users use Carto
with data observatory, which
is our repository of spatial
data, things like demographics,
mobility, financial data,
that is useful for doing
a lot of this analysis.
A lot of these datasets
will be collaborating
with the BigQuery
public datasets,
to make them available
to the Query community.
Now more widely, Carto
and Google Cloud Platform
provides a full solution of
what we call a next generation
spatial data infrastructure.
With components like the
AI Platform and BigQuery,
Google Cloud Platform
together with Carto,
provides a great
new way of thinking
about the spatial analysis.
And we have been
leveraging it, like we
said, a lot during COVID-19.
So let me show you
a few use cases.
So the first one, as
we were describing,
combining location data
with COVID-19 cases,
government can actually create
what we call risk models.
It can do risk
analysis to understand
which areas are more
vulnerable depending
on things like
demographics, like age,
to have a bigger
effect COVID-19.
Right, so these
type of analysis are
possible by combining a lot
of the datasets, some Shane,
you were talking before.
Now, another use case
that I like a lot,
and you put it before very well.
There's been an incredible
pressure on governments
to explain the reasons why
they are closing up or open up,
those lockdowns having
affected so many people.
And in order to
do that, they had
to be very responsible in the
way they publicize the data,
and how they explain
the stories behind it.
So helping to tell those
stories and make trends
get transparency, so that
makes it way more effective,
and makes it citizens
understands the importance
of those measurements.
Of course, another
typical call or use case
that we've been seeing, is
associating human mobility,
with changes on the economy.
We know when lockdowns
happens, the economy shrinks.
So trying to understand the
correlation between these two
factors, is a pretty
important factor.
It can help you to collect,
understand, and mitigate
the economic impact of COVID-19.
The next one is even like
a more practical things.
Like this situation
has made us, well,
have to collect deal about
like, how many people come
with feet on a beach, while
maintaining secure distance,
right?
So all those type
of analysis also
require a lot of light data
crunching and data analytics.
We see that particular
in cases where
we work with governments on
understanding the importance
of the lockdowns.
But also we've seen quite a
lot on the private sector.
So understanding the impact
for a particular retailer
of those lockdowns in the
different countries where
they're operating, so those
are also a very classical cases
where you're mixing data that
you have on the public datasets
together with your
own enterprise data,
in this case to see how COVID-19
is affecting your business.
And lastly, I think also
something that we've seen
and we've been working
a lot is understanding
and prepared working on data
around mobility inside offices.
As we know, more
businesses are opening up.
And we hear more
and more the need
for understanding like
mobility indoors, right?
So if you track movements of
employees while at the office,
you can obtain
reports like who's
been in contact with
whom, within three meters,
or in the same room.
Which parts of the office
produce more contacts?
How can you adapt timetables
to reduce those contacts?
Well, as you can see,
there's many use cases
where you can apply
spatial analytics together
with a spatial they
don't like, the one
that is available on the
BigQuery public datasets,
to fight on COVID-19.
So, what do you think, Shane?
SHANE GLASS: I think
it's a great idea.
Why don't we look at some demos?
I'll go first.
I'll show a couple of
queries in BigQuery
and we can come
back to you and show
how we can visualize those.
JAVIER DE LA TORRE:
Sounds great.
SHANE GLASS: OK.
Now let's take a
look at some examples
of how COVID-19 data can be
help used to flatten the curve.
We'll start here by
looking at COVID-19 cases
by county across the US,
and joining demographic data
from the Census Bureau's
American Community Survey.
The demo that we're
looking at here
gives us cases and deaths
by US county, and also
a litany of different
demographic factors,
including total population,
population density, income,
age, gender, and race.
This data can be used to help
contextualize an outbreak
and better understand some
potential factors that
are in play.
We can also use it to create a
dashboard in Looker, the newest
member of Google Cloud's family
for business intelligence.
This allows us to
visualize data, drill down
by county or state, and provide
contextual visualizations
around it.
Now let's take a look
at our next demo, which
is COVID-19 cases normalized
by county population,
in this case per 100,000.
Now we can quickly run
this query as well.
And we'll get a
result for the number
of cases within the
last day by US county.
But now, Javier, what if we
wanted to visualize a query
like this.
Could you show us what
that would look like?
JAVIER DE LA TORRE:
BigQuery is known
for handling large
amounts of data,
so visualizing large
amounts of data
sounds something that's
pretty much needed.
So for example, this data set
from New York City and the taxi
trips that is available on
BigQuery public data, that's
around 131 million GPS points.
We have found a way
to visualize this.
Here's a demo of that.
This is your 131 million
points visualized on the map.
And as you can see
as I zoom in, you
can see how the maps
gets loaded progressively
until if I zoom enough
each of these points
represents one of the
records in that table.
And this is possible
because we process the data
into what we call tile sets.
We've been working over
the last few months
to generate this task
starting from a query.
And we have a solution for it.
So you can see now we can
progress not hundreds of them,
we can process
billions of records
in very, very effectively,
using a query.
So using this tile
sets generation,
dialing from a query without
moving the data out of it,
you can get datasets like this
one, 300 million buildings
in the US, all the buildings
in the United States,
and territories, or
from within the query.
So if you're interesting to
use this type of technology
for tile set generation, we
have an open beta program.
And you can get
access by sending us
an email to BigQuery@Carto.
We think this will be
pretty relevant to people
who are working with very
large spatial datasets.
SHANE GLASS: That's
awesome, Javier.
Thanks for the demo.
I personally can't
wait to use Carto
to dig in a little
deeper, to figure out
why things are happening
where they're happening.
OK well, that's all for us
here today at Google Cloud Next
OnAir.
If you'd like to
learn more about how
you can use public data
to combat COVID-19,
check out the
following resources.
You can check out more specific
examples of how data science
and public data can support
public health efforts to fight
COVID-19 by watching our
Cloud OnAir webinar from May,
titled "Data science
for public health--
Working with public
COVID-19 datasets."
You can also check
out the full catalog
of public datasets
available on Google Cloud
by visiting the Google
Cloud Marketplace using
the short link on the right.
Additionally there are a number
of other Cloud Next OnAir
sessions talking about how
Google Cloud is helping support
the response to COVID-19.
There's so many to choose from.
From the industrial
insights session
on "Planning for
retail's new priorities,"
hosted by our VP of
retail, Carrie Tharp,
to the breakout session "Data
driven responses to COVID-19
using Looker and
BigQuery," hosted
by my friend and
colleague, Leigha Jarett,
who runs the product
demonstration for Looker.
In particular, I
recommend checking out
Aashima Gupta's talk
on reimagining health
care in COVID-19 era, and
Mike Daniels's session
on reimagining the public
sector in the COVID-19 era.
Both of these talks
do a really great job
of expanding on the
concepts we covered today.
That's all for us.
Thanks for watching
Google Cloud Next OnAir.